cet acte est convention signée entre le
département des yvelines et le château
de versailles pour la mise en place du
chantier de restauration de quatre
groupes sculptés sur l'ancienne friche
du site industriel dunlopillo situe à
mantes la jolie pour l'instant de son
surplace découpé en 85 palette elle
trônait normalement sur les piliers des
grilles de l'orangerie du château de
versailles la restauration va durer
environ 18 mois en septembre prochain
cet espace sera ouvert aux visiteurs un
jour par semaine on va montrer ce
travail aux habitants de mantes-la-jolie
aux jeunes qui pourront venir à la fois
voir ce que sont ces métiers le voir en
temps réel pouvoir même s'exercer à ce
travail et puis comprendre l'importance
que ak ce patrimoine non pas par rapport
au passé mais par rapport à l'avenir
avant l'ouverture tout public une
première opération aura lieu cet été
auprès des jeunes issus des quartiers
politique de la ville et de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance dans le cadre de
l'été royal entre juillet et août ce
seront trois mille jeunes à peu près
entre 6 ans et 18 ans donc avec des
ateliers prévus pour eux est adapté à ce
qu'il a la rage notamment et bien qu'ils
pourront venir ici découvrir ses travaux
autour de la pierre et puis ensuite
venir découvrir le château de versailles
lors de la signature de la convention le
département des yvelines a officialisé
la création d'un tiers lieux culturels
sur le site de lusine dunlopillo fermé
depuis 2020 diverses associations
orienté cultures urbaines comme le graff
le breakdance ou encore la glisse
urbaine était présente pour donner un
avant goût de ce que va devenir cet
espace 2000 440 m² plutôt que d'avoir
une espèce de friches qu'on garde yens
ou alors aux comptes démolissent tous
les bâtiments et connaît un espace vide
absolument pas glamour et sans usage ça
serait vraiment dommage et ça va être le
premier tiers lieu en ile de france
en grande couronne un appel à
manifestation d'intérêt va donc être
lancée en attendant le bâtiment et ses
abords sont en cours de rénovation
coût total des travaux estimé à un peu
moins d'un million d'euros